[Music]
okay Jenny now we just got done seeing
what was it called possession what is
that [ __ ] of Hannah grace yeah
possession Hannah grace uh what you
think of me Jane um not bad not actually
what I was expecting
it kind of starts out like the cold open
starts out like a pretty standard like
idea style possession movie but then it
kind of goes off in an interesting
direction becomes a monster movie basis
sort of yeah and it's kind of like the
setting if it was great it's pretty much
said entirely like in this really
cavernous like creepy morgue where this
girl works yeah you know where the
possessed girl gets brought in yeah I
can't with it it actually reminds me if
you guys have seen and I think it might
still be on Netflix there's a movie
called last shift that's about like a
female cop and she kind of gets this
crappy assignment oh she has to like
kind of babysitting this abandoned
police station for one night while they
get all the stuff out of it and you know
it's pretty much said in one location
with only a couple of characters yeah
not many characters in hey yeah so it
kind of reminded me a little bit of that
I don't know I actually really liked it
I like it was kind of like a slow burn
very atmospheric movie was shot well it
looked the the acting and it was very
good lots of good scenes in it for me
that was kind of the problem the seems
like they shot good stuff so they put it
all in there
the Edit isn't very tight I was kinda
getting lost and getting bored and there
are a lot of story elements that I
didn't really care about like you know
there were a lot of references about
drug problems and depression and well I
think they tried to make that relevant
is the possession yeah
metaphor but you know you I'm not
sophisticated in that way I just see
that as whining I don't really care
about it I just want to know where that
damn monsters at though because there's
a monster crawling around I really
didn't think the monster was too scary
it's a little ginger naked chick running
around like a rock head on Flocka that's
kind of what she looks like which that
doesn't scare me at the end as they
started to win against this thing they
didn't do the typical thing that you
want to do you want to destroy that
monster and then all of a sudden you
find out that the monster is even worse
than that so really what I would have
done if I had I directed it is how to
burn the girl up alright and then the
demon comes out and you got to fight
that that's what I would have done
although I feel like to do that yeah
right the the tone of the movie the way
the edit was very serious so they're
trying to it almost was like The Shining
level serious but I just can't really
take it seriously I think I think horror
movies are better is like fun action
movies with or really [ __ ] gross
something like centipede there's a human
centipede there's nothing wrong yeah
that's the thing there's really nothing
wrong with the way the movie looked yeah
the movie looked good it's just it was
just the tone of the movie the edit and
everything it just wasn't to my taste
maybe somebody else might like it like I
said go into it expecting it's more like
um you know like I said it's not
over-the-top metaphorical but you could
tell that they were going for kind of a
more of a metaphor for the metaphorical
type of thing and also you know it is
rather slow moving rather it's it's all
about building atmospheres like that
then there's like a couple of jump
scares but it's not really it's not
super fast paced yeah I know just go
into it with that in mind me I think I
would prefer prefer bit and it is and
done along the lines to say like from
beyond or reanimate
you gotta mean that I woulda liked that
I didn't like it but like I said it
reminded me a blast shift and I probably
liked last shift a lot better but this
actually wasn't bad and I like that it
kind of subverted my expectations
because I was thinking it was just gonna
be like a shirt yeah like one of those
but it was actually kind of different I
didn't think there was enough to end up
to it it's just we're just gonna have
differences that's that that's it's
gonna depend on it's gonna defensible
it's gonna depend on your tastes and
what your expectations are yeah I
typically don't like these kind of
horror movies I don't find it scary
enough that I find them to be kind of
boring I would have liked I said I would
have liked it better be on you know men
or like you know monster movie in the
end where you got to kill the thing two
or three different times and every time
like a boss fight you know I don't liked
it on this kinda like 80s style I think
I would like that a little bit better to
say though every time we come see a
horror movie always excited because I
would see the Pet Sematary trailer and
that looks like that looks pretty good
there's some good stuff coming this
wasn't one of them though for me like I
said it's not right yeah you know it's
it's alright it's a perfectly - yeah
alright then I think that's always we
can only say
you
okay we're
I am see again we this time we saw what
was this called boy boy erased which is
common all star cast had Russell Crowe
Russell Crowe you got big bro but he
know what he looks he fits he looks
exactly like the real guy yes because
they should have the real people I guess
he packed on some weight too
I got a hand and then he had head Tom
Cruise his ex-wife was in this enormous
anemic old Kidman yes she was still like
a five shilling a fine but they gave her
a pocket yeah that kind of made her I
liked okay
well that's what the original that's
what the actual that's what she looked
like like yeah but movies about taking
place in the South about a Southern
Baptist couples preacher turns out his
sons gay so he sends them to a gay camp
pray the gay we pray the gay away action
yeah this is actually based on it's not
true sir his memoir like those kids at
this kids member he's a kid obviously
but he was 18 or 19 what happened yeah
um the thing that I really liked about
this movie is that they didn't portray
anyway I mean obviously the whole pray
the gay away thing is deeply warped and
creepy and it's kind of like and you
kind of get that sense for because I'm
like a few scenes at this I was like my
god it was like a horror get creeping me
out but it's like everybody in it is
portrayed the way they where they are
though sympathetically I mean everybody
in this I mean even though a lot of them
do some misguided things they're also a
better way to put it that they're all
well-intentioned no one is a villain um
you know no one is doing anything on
purpose
you know what I mean it's like and I
like that the kid you know he didn't
hate his parents he didn't you know he
had complicated feelings about them but
they didn't think they were doing
in bad and he actually kind of chose to
go they asked you know we think you
should go to this and he said that he he
I don't want to be gay anymore and send
me you know so he goes to the place and
it ends up being kind of a horror show
me and Jenny of course we're products at
a South we live here we have people like
this in our family you know this goes
back generations these [ __ ] saw the
badness so we're very well you know
we're really familiar with the dot that
the thinking of religious people it's
not just the southern thing there's a
certain kind of people that are just
religious and no matter where they are
they're gonna be religious and they have
it you know if they're in [ __ ] they
might they could be Muslims they could
be Scientologists they could be anything
they're like that that's exactly what
they're like so to me actually the
movies just kind of boring because like
uh yeah yeah well you we take we know
this culture were they well like I said
it was an interesting story I liked
because I had heard about places like
this and like read articles about places
like this but it was interesting to see
it from the perspective of somebody that
had been in there yeah you know and this
wasn't even one of the real super bad
ones yeah I'm going like this is pretty
mild
yeah but you can I mean but you can see
we're from this area we're from this
culture so we know how extreme religious
ariados can get and here's something
else I've got to say this most religious
most southern people aren't like this
well yeah it's not like that we're smart
enough to know see that for what it is
right yeah they're a minority even here
we're smart enough to see that for what
it is yeah most most most most of us
just avoid religion altogether yeah I
mean they were
debates about money and when really when
you get into the the conversion clinic
where this is happening they didn't know
what they were doing they were just
trying to make money look at many
students in yeah when you say when you
take any kind of scripture and you don't
really know what the scripture means and
you try to apply it to something the
scripture isn't talking about bad [ __ ]
happens well unlike I said me that that
whole like small minority of light is
kind of fundamentalist Christian like
you know Southern Baptists type of thing
that are like super super worried about
other sexuality that is a deeply dear to
me I thought it was boring really
because not much really happened I mean
anymore they didn't beat him they didn't
torture him it wasn't really anything
it's just it's sitting around put hands
on you and pray and think stupid it's
just ridiculous it's just ridiculous
creepy yeah well it's about making money
and like I said more than like a
straight-up horror show in some ways
which made it creepier to me because
it's like it would you would be
hard-pressed be like you know like I
said they didn't like beat him up or
anything like that but it's just like I
don't know it works on you mentally and
it's just like in some ways that's kind
of it's not worse I love this guy [ __ ]
I'm not I'm not a sucker you can't
really talk me into that kind of [ __ ]
and eventually the kid did realize that
he can just leave but you like the
moment was really good in it I thought
it was a well made movie the acting was
very solid it was very accurate very
accurate did I like the movie boring
yeah well it's it's an indie movie it's
just like something that I could just go
to the street and see you did just go to
the street you know I'm saying though
right there just step into the church
eat on I mean and just hear some fools
go on and on about scripture you know
and he doesn't even know what he's
talking about
well I really well if you like that kind
of you know whiter independent movies
yeah if you want if you want to be like
entertained see [ __ ] blow up shooting
stuff and you know everybody knows
that's all you want a tease yeah you
don't wanna see this one
okay it's that time of the month we're
scrounging for movies to watch we're at
the bottom of the barrel and there we
only had like a couple choices so we
decided to see this one about a kpop
band books are called burn stage
literally we have seen every movie in
this theater but we've seen every other
to the one yeah
so I said okay well they're showing yeah
Korean k-pop band you know yeah that's
bad yeah so it's like so I had no idea
that these dudes were like this
cuz like this movie has been playing for
probably like three weeks yeah like it's
shower two a day and it was like pretty
full and there was like all kind that's
not a little girls in there and they
[ __ ] loved it and I'm going like what
the [ __ ] are they laughing it it just
sucked well it was a documentary so like
I said if you're not a fan obviously
it's going to come across as like very
repetitive yeah you know it's like a
little bit of stage let's actually talk
about it though was this a documentary
no it was well no it wasn't it was a
bunch of clips yeah from strung together
of lie informants a couple little stage
things at a bunch of little poetry not
really a documentary is more of a
commercial yeah a very long trying to be
like I said it reminded me like I said I
I don't know it reminded me of like a
documentary about them where it's like
if you don't you know if you don't know
who they are you don't know anything
about them yeah you don't know anything
that because they won't tell young about
me wrong they seem like nice they seem
like really a boys and that you know
what I mean so it was like I had no idea
they were this famous because like I'm
old and like I said yeah the time the
target target audiences maybe like
thirteen year olds but they played like
in the US and there's like sold-out vans
and like
these dudes yeah they weigh like 110
pounds you can tell they're ended like
this you know Japan and Korea you know I
lived in korea koreas are real they live
really like cutesy [ __ ] you know Nemea
and so you got these little hundred and
ten pound dudes up there in their
twenties singing this cutie [ __ ] and
then a drop of the Hat they'll do this
[ __ ] Eminem knockoff song trying to be
hard and it just makes you laugh but the
girls like it you know I do this [ __ ] I
watch this just so you don't have to
there was literally only two choices
we've said everything else in this
theater and we're not like driving
farther ticket yeah theater and we know
we actually one of the things we one of
the one of the criteria one of the
things that say we'll see this one
because it was short yeah that's it
short it so I like how much like an hour
21 minutes something like that but yeah
so like I said it was it was our it's
lit it wasn't all right but like I said
if it's not if you're not a fan then
yeah it's for fans it's free very young
and the females you're a man you want to
stay we're mission otherwise yeah and
you're not gonna think those dudes are
cute unless you're gay you're straight
man you don't want to see this dude like
you
you're there now let's do from that cute
okay
you